et aujourd'hui on a une telle
contestation sur la question du port du
masque généralisée il faut comprendre
d'où ça vient ça vient pas d'un
complotisme ambiance ça vient aussi du
fait que les mêmes dirigeants qui
aujourd'hui nous explique le port du
masque est absolument impératif
hier nous expliquer qu' il ne fallait
surtout pas le porter et donc cette
incohérence de la parole publique
elle a créé ce grand brouillon je ne
comprends rien sur les tests puisque
j'entends et c'est bien naturel il faut
se tester mais les résultats mettent
parfois quelques heures quelques jours
j'entendais même certains en sologne qui
attendent 7 8 10 jours pour avoir les
les résultats il ya beaucoup à dire sur
le sujet la façon dont les choses sont
gérées aujourd'hui songez que l'on
manque de réactifs pour faire des tests
aujourd'hui donc la situation est quand
même des plus préoccupantes depuis le
début de cette crise sanitaire tout le
monde nous dit tout le monde convient
que les tests sont au coeur de la
stratégie
le ministre la santé n'a pas cessé de le
répéter et depuis plusieurs mois nous
nous rendons compte que le pays n'est
pas du tout organisé pour permettre les
tests il faut plus qu'un plan il faut un
choc de relance c'est ce dont notre pays
a besoin c'est parti dans les
orientations générales ou paraissent
bonnes a oui c'est pas un choc de
relance allez vous dire 100 milliards ça
ne vous semble pas mais c'est la mise en
oeuvre qu'il convoque le plan de relance
et doit pas être un prétexte à un rien
faire d'autre on peut pas sans arrêt
annoncé des réformes mais jamais les
faire donc il ya un moment donné le plan
de relance il doit pas servir de mon
train pendant 18 mois pour la pour la
france
il faut continuer bon gré mal gré
contrevent assez compliquée avec une
situation sociale très épidermique et
très instable et en même temps la france
son vrai plan de relance serait qu'elle
se réforment plus en profondeur
quelles réformes son modèle pour que ce
modèle soit durable en glace français a
lancé avec retard sur le calendrier le
gouvernement lui même avait prévu on
sent qu aujourd'hui il faut
effectivement que ce choc puisse
intervenir
nous avons vécu une crise économique
sans précédent organisée d'une certaine
manière par les mesures que l'état lui
même avait mises en oeuvre pour faire
face à la pandémie
maintenant il faut que l'état soit au
rendez vous pour pouvoir impulser c'est
parce qu'ils n'ont visiblement pas
besoin de leurs adversaires pour se
caricaturer il semble véritable
caricature et simplement je constate à
quel point cette démarche vouloir punir
en permanence les français de vouloir
considérer que tout ce qui est populaire
est forcément mauvais est advenu tout à
fait insupportable
je pense que l'environnement la défense
de l'environnement mérite mieux que ces
écologistes
obsédé sur des bricoles les verts
d'extrême gauche qui porte une idéologie
que je considérais que nous considérons
comme dangereuse
c'est une vision du monde et je crois
qu'on aurait tort de
prendre à la légère beaucoup ont choisi
de s'en moquer moi je crois que c'est
très sérieux et que c'est très
inquiétant aujourd'hui le sentiment
d'insécurité c'est pas le sentiment
c'est une réalité vécue au quotidien et
dans beaucoup de nos compatriotes sont
sentis très touchée personnellement très
impliqué très concerné par cette affaire
de théoule-sur-mer totalement ahurissant
totalement ahurissant c'est aujourd'hui
sont extrêmement et qui inquiet
préoccupé par l'évolution la criminalité
la délinquance et il faut que certains
qui sont aujourd'hui en position de
décider les écoute il faut que cette
bien pensants ce qui depuis des années
me et conteste l'évolution de la
criminalité de la délinquance jusqu'au
garde des sceaux qui parle de sentiment
d'insécurité dit circulez ya rien à voir
il n'ya pas d'insécurité dans notre pays
comment peut-on affirmer avec une telle
arrogance un tel déni la restauration de
la laïcité de tous ces sujets sur la
radicalisation est un angle mort aussi
de ce gouvernement monsieur macron
promet depuis des semaines et des
semaines des grandes déclarations sur le
sujet sauf que finalement de
l'impression par manque de courage il
n'en dit rien
[Musique]